Donald Trump by all reasonable reports
is about to get arrested again indicted
again this time on federal charges these
aren't even the only federal charges
Trump might be charged for remember that
there is a federal investigation into
Trump's mishandling of classified
documents which we now know took place
not only at Mar-A-Lago but also at
Bedminster we now know Trump knew they
were classified based on an audio
recording of trump saying I have a
document here but I can't show it to you
because it's classified which confirms
Trump knew he had not actually
Declassified the documents that's one
slate of federal charges that could be
coming
in addition there are the potential
charges referred to the justice
department by the former house committee
investigating the insurrectionist Trump
Riots of January 6 2021